so we've now confirmed not just the
dates but also the moderators and the
locations of the upcoming three
presidential debates and the one vice
presidential debate
and joe biden is demanding live fact
checking during the debates which
obviously donald trump
will oppose but we're going to get to
that in a minute
uh there's still some debate over
whether one or or both of the candidates
are going to back out you have some
trumpists
saying biden's going to find a way out
that biden
cognitively can't do it he would be
crushed by trump's
incredible intellect and cognitive
abilities and that biden will find some
way out he'll say a few days before the
event that he has coveted or something
like that
i don't think that that's going to
happen i think biden very much
understands that not debating
would not be particularly good for him
on the other hand
there are those who think trump is going
to try to find some way out either
because he'd be scared that
he won't be able to do to biden what he
did to hillary clinton in terms of kind
of stalking behind her and standing
physically close and that
i i think that they're probably going to
debate if i had to bet
now the debates are going to be on fox
news c-span and nbc
cnn shut out of the debates for the
first time since 2008
looking at the details september 29th
chris wallace will moderate a debate on
fox news
in cleveland ohio it will have six
15-minute segments
with two minutes per question i'm going
to get to that in a moment
on october 7th there will be a vp debate
susan page from usa today will be
moderating it it'll be at the university
of utah in salt lake city it will be
nine 10-minute segments two minutes per
question
the second presidential will be on
october 15th steve scully from c-span
will do it in miami florida
it'll be a town minute format with two
minutes per question
with an additional minute as needed and
then lastly the third debate will be
moderated by kristen welker of nbc
on october 22nd that's very close to
voting day
same format as the first debate so a few
thoughts first of all
the format favors donald trump anything
shorter
favors trump and you really can't do
anything
in two or three minutes i mean the the
issues that these individuals are
dealing with
are complex issues where if you had a
deep understanding of them you would
want
three to four minutes just to lay out
that you understand the issue that's how
you would have serious conversation
these debates are not set up for
information purposes
these debates are set up for
entertainment purposes
and the shorter it is the more it favors
donald trump because
i believe it's clear joe biden is the
one able to go deeper
in terms of policy than donald trump so
that's number one now number two
um the late debates the trump
administration has been trying to push
for
the trump campaign for an additional
debate early this month
because they recognize the more people
vote early
the fewer people left to convince will
be remaining
on october 22nd and that's true i do
think that
on october 22nd you're going to have a
smaller portion of the electorate
arguably than in any prior election due
to early voting and expanded absentee
ballot access
that probably is good for joe biden
in the sense that it's trump who is
likely to
pull some kind of october surprise and
the more people that have already sent
in their ballots or voted early
whenever trump pulls it the less
effective it's going to be for him
now on the fact checking biden
previously said
he wants some kind of live fact checking
of the president on screen
trump's obviously against it it doesn't
seem like it's going to happen and so
it's going to be up to joe biden to do
the fact checking
um i don't need debates this year i've
said it
it's never been clearer to me who we
should be supporting
but for those who want to see debates
and again they'll be entertaining i
don't think they'll be super informative
we will be doing live streams of all
four
the three presidential and the one vp
debate i think the vp debate
kamala harris is just going to uh eat
mike pence up and spit him out i just
don't see any way
in which pence gets through it unscathed
unscathed his followers won't care
they'll refuse to acknowledge it but i
think it's going to be very very bad for
mike pence